retrouver manger
svutés avec Mutualia la mutuelle des
[Musique]
territoires bonjour on est sur le pont
saint-bénzet ah pas trop connu sous ce n
là mais si je vous parle du Palais des
Papes le Ventou Château Neuf du pape
Gorde le Luberon évidemment nous sommes
sur le pont David Gon et on va visiter
ensemble avec manger s vé le beau
Vaucluse en compagnie du sénateur
Jean-Baptiste blanc sénateur du groupe
les républiicain au Sénat et vous allez
voir on va se
régaler
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur le sénateur savez que
je vous trouverai au au sommet du Ventou
absolument mais déjà on voit tout on
voit les Mones voclus on voit le Luberon
la Sainte Victoire au fond jusqu'à la
mer on voit les Alpes derrière nous
c'est notre mont fugi c'est notre
montsmichel signateur vous parlez
beaucoup du Ventou mais moi j'ai envie
d'entendre parler de vous ouis moi je
suis né à viignon je suis de Cavaillon
je me suis lancé c'était au début des
années 90 à travers François Léotard
l'Europe la décentralisation l'individu
les libertés tout ça me parlait vraiment
beaucoup et un de nos premiers combats
avec une terre de viticulture comme
celle-là ça a été celui de la loi é1
mais pour dire qu'on peut tout à fait
concilier la culture le terroir et même
la santé en buvant raisonnablement et
puis après je suis devenu tout
simplement élu local à Cavaillon d'abord
à la jeunesse qui é c'est un mandat
extraordinaire c'est là où je me suis le
plus éclaté et après le conseil
départemental le Sénat il y a 3 ans
châonut du pape gigondass vaceras
l'appellation Ventou celle du Luberon
comment ne pas les défendre c'est la
vigne et avec le le vin mais il y a
aussi l'huile d'olive l'huile d'olive et
ça sera mon mon vote effectivement une
petite phrase que j'ai noté votter pour
l'huile d'olive je vote pour l'huile
d'olive alors écoutons Mistral nous
autres les bons provençaux au suffrage
universel nous voterons pour l'huile et
nous ferons la Yoli ah bon alors vous
avez une obligation c'est maintenant de
m'emmener visiter un producteur d'olives
allons-y où est-ce qu'on va on va à
cadené exactement on a une longue
journée qui nous attend on va goûter
ensemble les petits fromages de chèvre
d'Emmanuel avant de goûter la cuisine
maison de Bernadette qui cuisine pour 80
élèves de l'école primaire de lourdmarin
on dégustera les magnifiques légumes du
maréchage de Nicolas my avant de goûter
le vin de Nancy au domaine de camarette
et de finir à table avec la chef Nadia
Samut mais tout de suite direction la
Bastille du Laval et ses huiles
[Musique]
merveilleuse monsieur bonjour bonjour
Rand enchanté ça c'est votre chaîne qui
garde les oliviers c'est ouais c'est la
mascotte du moulin en fait elle aime
beaucoup poser comme vous pouvez le voir
alors combien d'hectares de livivret le
domaine fait 30 hectares mais on a que
15 hectares d'Olivier voilà 4000 arbres
rart sur 15 hectares des variétés
locales de l'AOP Provence on a la chance
d'être sur une AOP historiquement dans
notre région le l'oliviers n'était pas
la culture principale d'ailleurs tous
les oliviers étaient pantés sur les
restan ou sur les Ribes comme on dit ici
il y avait rarement des oliviers en
plein champ un peu mais pas beaucoup on
s'est intéressé à la qualité de
l'olivier avec un peu de retard on a
vécu une révolution sur la qualité du
vin dans notre riggion je suis arrivé il
y a 25 ans cétait pas ce qu' y avait de
mieux aujourd'hui on a des vins de très
grande qualité qui sont produit dans la
région cette révolution est en train de
se faire sur l'huile d'olive voilà quand
on voit un paysage comme celui-ci
comment ne pas penser à la Toscane
peut-être en mieux he d'ailleurs quelle
fierté aussi de retrouver l'huile
d'olive de cadoné et du Laval à la table
du Sénat et puis sén vous avez sonhuile
bien sûr parce qu'on m'a dit qu'il y
avait des huiles au Sénat mais j'imagine
pas ces huiles là c'est mieux celle-là
je pense
d'ailleurs je ne rentrerai pas dans ce
débat je vous laisse libre de vos propos
Roland vous êtes en bio ici on est en
bio tout le domaine est en bio oui c'est
faire du bio sur l'olivier c'est pas
très très compliqué en fait il y a la
mouche quand même alors la mouche de
l'olive on la combat très bien c'est
notre parasite c'est notre ennemi public
numéro 1 qui qui pon ses œufs dans
l'olive pour faire très très rapide on
traite les oliviers avec de la caolinite
calcinée de la de la poussière de
blancheolin qui sert à faire la la
porcelaine notamment exactement si la
polinisation se fait par le vent il n'y
a aucun insecte polisateur pour les
oliviers non et et surtout pas l'abeille
elle ne butine pas la fleur d'Olivier le
pollen de l'olivier est extrêmement fin
il est peu chargé en sucre et cetera
elle est pas intéressé non donc
l'aérologie est super importante très
importante Roland on est bien ici là en
surplombant votre olivret justement on
est tellement bien à l'ombre on s'est
dit tiens pour vous avvez planqué des
bouteilles dans l'ivra absolument allez
allons-y ou là là voilà lequel vous vous
plaî le plus à vous ah ben nous on a
notre championne du monde qui est
l'ardance qui est très verte elle va
racler la gorge elle est vraiment
champion du monde d'ailleurs elle est
vraiment championne du monde ou ou oui
il faut le savoir alors vous pouvez
constater sur l'ensemble de de nos
huiles il y en a qu'une qui est en
bouteille transparente ou il se trouve
que c'est la meilleure alors c'est une
hérésie l'huile d'olive c'est tris et
demi et c'est écrit sur toutes les
bouteilles sont la chaleur l'oxygène et
la lumière l'huile d'olive doit être
conservé à l'abri de la lumière donc
dans la cave comme le vin absolument je
vais goûter Votre championne du monde
alors
allez-y moi elle la cuit pas
moins alors on l'appelle ardance
l'ardance c'est le piquant en fait dans
notre voilà la voilà la
l'arbance ça reste très énergétique donc
il faut pas en manger trop non je suis
très impressionné quand même par
celle-ci là qui qui réveille plein de de
souvenir même absolument faut rappeler
peut-être que euh la production
française parce que là ce sont des
huiles de haute qualité ça pèse rien du
tout en Europe et encore moins dans le
monde la France c'est 0,4 % de la
production mondiale c'est 4 % de ce
qu'elle consomme tout le reste est
importé et l'Espagne premier producteur
oui avec 48 % à peu près ouais la moitié
des OL de l'huile d'olive faite dans le
monde ça vient d'Espagne c'est ça notre
seul porte de sortie c'est de faire du
très haut de gamme voilà nous en tous
les cas c'était notre CRÉO dès le départ
en fait une bonne huile d'olive c'est
exactement comme un bon vin vous l'avez
repéré vous savez que c'est celui-là que
vous aimez et bien vous y revenez
régulièrement merci Roland merci
beaucoup c'était une belle dégustation
et ça m'a complètement habillé le palais
oui oui il y en a pour un petit moment
on n pas terminé notre journée monsieur
pas terminé merci
[Musique]
beaucoup dites-moi Jean-Baptiste on est
déjà entouré de chèvres là donc
j'imagine bien qu'on va aller visiter un
chevrier un chevrier qui s'appelle
Emmanuel un travail exceptionnel nous
avons 40 chevriers dans notre
département nous sommes très très
fierers et je vois Emmanuel là-bas noyé
dans ses chèvres bonjour Emmanuel
bonjour bonjour manuel vous n'êtes pas
un pâtre de naissance ah non je suis pas
pas issu du milieu agricole non vous
êtes venu sur le tard je suis venu sur
le tard en 2014 voilà ça fait maintenant
9 ans que j'ai choisi de d'élever des
chèvres et de produire du du fromage de
chèvres dans le dans le
voocluse je crois que vous travailler
des cahiers lactiques he c'est ça
essentiellement du lactique fromage ou
les crru et vous rendez compte que les
bactéries dans le vivant il y en a qui
sont bonnes et qui protège le fromage
naturel je ne feraai pas un fromage sans
bactéries j'ai besoin des bactéries pour
faire du bon fromage ou vous monsieur
sénateur on sent bien que vous avez
vraiment cet amour de ce territoire de
ce terroir les marchés de producteurs on
en voit beaucoup en vos Cluses et arrête
de manger mon blouson toi dans La
Provence effectivement il y a les
marchés les marchés de notre département
sont très connus en le vous on aaime pas
trop les intermédiaires on a des marchés
de producteurs aussiu Emmanuel en fait
quelques uns j'ai fait le choix d'une
vente pratiquement à 100 % en vente
directe donc en vente à la ferme marché
de producteur et en a map donc moi
personnellement non je ne pourrais pas
me passer de la vente directe et cette
année on été particulièrement sèche dans
le vocluse c'est une catastrophe ça pour
vous en terme de production laitière en
terme de production laitière oui on a
une une forte baisse de production par
rapport aux années précédentes vous
l'estimez à combien à peu près à peu
près une moitié je pense ah oui ouais 50
% de de de lait en moins ouais monsieur
le sénateur toutes ces résurgences elles
sont mises à mal par la sécheresse c'est
peut-être le sujet le plus important
qu'on a on a appréhendé aujourd'hui on
parle de 60 à 80 % de pluie en moins
dans notre région évidemment l'urgence
climatique oblige tous nos producteurs à
revoir la façon de faire après nous
sommes une région qui a quand même
beaucoup de chance c'est qu'on a le
canal Saint-Julien à cabillon le canal
de Carpentra on a le rô qui est pas très
loin donc on a quand même des solutions
et on travaille avec les collectivités
locales et l'État bien entendu à amener
l'eau encore partout mais ce sont des
sujets très lourds et qui vont demander
du temps or il y a urgence parce que
nous sommes le jardin de la France et
nous attentendons le rester vous vous
avez vraiment fait le choix provinçal
j'ai fait le choix des des rustique pour
se démarquer justement par rapport aux
autres se démarquer par rapport à la
qualité comme je le dis toujours une
chèvre Durov une chèvre provençale va
faire entre 1 L 1 L et demi par jour là
où une chamoisée peut faire trois ou
quatre sans problème donc il y a des
contraintes dans la mesure où ça nous
oblige à avoir ben beaucoup plus de
chèvr que les collègues mais le but est
d'avoir un rendu fromage meilleur
gustativement vraiment ça fait la
différence gativement le lait de chèvre
du rve de provençal est plus riche plus
plus de matièrees Grasse plus de
protéines donc c'est des choses qui vont
jouer sur la qualité et sur le goût du
fromage ouais moi je serais pas du genre
à croire sur parole plutôt à goûter on
va goûter on va
[Musique]
goûter je vous en prie hein alors c'est
bien ça c'est à peine gélifié quoi on
sentore bien humide oui on est presque
sur un fromage frais comme on pourrait
le manger à la cuillère vous Emmanuel
vous n'êtes pas bio non c'est un choix
on y est tout proche on aurait ce
problème du foin pas forcément
disponible sur le secteur et puis à un
coup un coup beaucoup plus élé
oui et puis on s'est posé la question de
ce que ça pourrait nous apporter dans la
mesure où les clients voilà ont la
possibilité de venir à la ferme de voir
notre système d'élevage de voir comen
sont bichonner nos chèvres et donc on n
pas poussé plus loin et ça démarche au
fond quand on l'analyse bien elle est
encore plus vertueuse que le bio elle
est naturelle quoi elle est naturelle ça
rejoint une réflexion qu'on doit avoir
de manières général est-ce qu'on va tout
régir à coup de norme et de
planification où est-ce qu'on peut faire
confiance au aux acteurs on voit bien
quand on a une identité forte qu'on
donne de la de l'autonomie c'est de
liberté qu'on fait confiance aux acteurs
locaux on est beaucoup plus fort c'est
la bonne échelle on ne fait les choses
bien que de près donc seraitant que ce
pays là songe à décentraliser vraiment
donc ce n'est pas parce que j'ai une
identité forte vusienne et provençale
que je ne me sens pas français contra au
contraire et même européen donc ça veut
dire que je suis pluriel mais c'est très
[Musique]
important
jour de marché à lourdmin on sait où
trouver le maire pas loin des produits
bonjour monsieur le maamp moi j'adore
les champignons ah ben là on a des ses
qui sont beau là c'est magnifique alors
j'ai pas pu venir avec monsieur le
sénateur mais il m'a dit va voir la
cantine de lourdmin parce que c'est un
exemple pour tout le mondesolument c'est
loin d'ici non à TR pas et ben on y va
allez école Philippe de Girard mais
dites donc Monsieur le Maire je vois que
le menu est affiché sauter d'agneau
ribio
oh j'ai raté la Pan cot hier prochaine
fois je viendra la veille d'accord belle
école provinçale quand vous étiez min
vous c'était déjà ici absolument donc
vous êtes sur les lieux de votre école
primaire là et il y a des traces de mes
sculptures ah c'est parce que vous êtes
mare qu' les ont garder pas du tout pas
du
tout
[Musique]
bonjour Bernadette bonjour Qu'est-ce que
vous étiez en train de faire c'est le
fameux saué d'agneau que j'ai vu un oui
c'est ça saué d'agneau et j'ai ajouté un
peu des épices pour faire un peu tagine
depuis 30 ans ça veut dire que vous
faites la cuisine que vous faites chez
vous voilà à peu près oui mais ça c'est
incroyable ça oui mais c'est ce qui fait
la différence cher Monsieur ah non mais
je je suis bien d'accord mais je suis
saisi et c'est assez difficile parce
qu'avec toutes les normes maintenant
tout ce qu'on nous impose la loi égalime
avec toutes les contraintes c'est de
plus en plus difficile combien vous avez
d'élèves ici alors là aujourd'hui ben en
tout on est 81 élèves les adultes on est
à 88 seul en cuisine pour 90 personnes
et je commence à 9h du matin oui parce
que ce que vous gérez c'est aussi les
achats achat la la comptabilité de votre
cuisine c'est comme si vous aviez un
restaurant à l'intérieur de
l'établissement scolaire exactement la
même chose la viande c'est ce qui a très
cher oui et à l'intérieur de la viande
on sait bien que l'agneau du sauté
d'agneau et sûrement que vous prenez de
l'épaule par exemple ah vous prenez
gigot en plus j'ai pr du G je peux vous
dire que mon gigot je l'ai négocié et
c'est de l'agneau des Alpes qui vient de
en plus d'un fournisseuroui vous êtes le
locavor au maximum au maximum du coup
est-ce que ça vous oblige certains jours
à avoir des menus végétariens c'est
obligatoire oui j'ai un menu végétarien
par par semaine alors ça c'est
obligatoire sur le plan de la
législation dans le sens de manger moins
mais mieux parce que c'est déterminant
dans le
dans le bien-être à l'école on sait très
bien que pour certains c'est le meilleur
repas de la journée donc il faut faut
pas louper ça écoutez Bernadette je je
vais vous demander un truc oui de de
goûter Votre sauté d'agneau alors j'ai
pas encore goûté moi donc ah alors pour
l'assaisonnement peut-être qu'il faudra
rtifier l'assaisonnement allez me
chercher un petit morceau s'il vous
plaît voilà je voulais un peu effilocher
ah c'est bon ça
on peut réserver une
table mais mais j'ai besoin de savoir
quelque chose le tarif du menu combien
vous vendez ça aux famillees pour ceux
qui payent le moins c'est 2,90 € et ceux
qui paye le plus c'est
3,59 ça fait une moyenne à 326 dépendant
du cotient familial sachant que le coût
de revient d'un repas en comptant les
achats le personnel sur et C c'est 5,84
€ vous êtes sur la fin de votre carrière
làou vous allez bientôt partir j'espère
oui pourquoi j'espère parce qu'ils
veulent pas vous lâcher exactement
exactement ça que je vais faire dans
cette émission quelque chose que je ne
fais jamais agence de recrutement si
vous habitez le sud Luberon ou la région
dans leevaucluse que vous avez des
talents de cuisinier ou de cuisinière
vous pouvez envoyer votre candidature
pour suppler et ensuite succéder à
Bernadette ici à la cantine scolaire de
Lourmarin continue le plus longtemps
possible partez pas tout de suite je
vais essayer au revoir Monsieur le Maire
au revoir au plaisir et merci il faut
que j'aille retrouver le sénateur qui
lui a le ventre vide faut pas trop que
je lui parle de l'agneau d'ici
[Musique]
absolument bonjour bonjour ce sénateur
vous m'avez manqué également Nicolas my
c'est ça votre cœur d'activité c'est
quoi j'ai décidé c'est un choix de cœur
de reprendre le flamb familial et de
faire la production de fruits et légumes
ou mais alors sur mon exploitation c'est
en partie des raisins alors raisin not
table essentiellement un peu de raisin
pour faire du vin vinifiant coopérative
et l'autre moitié c'est la production de
fruits et légumes marchage du maréchage
toute l'année Nicolas donc c'est aussi
ces magasins alors ça c'est important on
peut pas être juste producteur
aujourd'hui il faut aller jusqu'à l'acte
de vente finale au grand public faire du
marché de gros ça a été à certains
moment économiquement étranglant tout ce
que vous gagnez vous le perdez en
transport livr de la fraîcheur c'est
passer son temps sur la route
quotidiennement transport mais monsieur
le sénateur les axe de communication
c'est la vallée du rô c'est pas si
facile d'accès cette est du Luberon ils
sont tournés aujourd'hui vers ex et
Marseille il y a une métropole à nos
portes métropole dont nous ne voulons
pas je le dis tout de suite nous voulons
vivre mieux donc c'est un peu le rôle du
Conseil départemental he de travailler
cette solidarité rurale ce réseau de
ville et et de village et après il y a
le Nicolas social qui met de la
solidarité et de la justice dans ces
prix j'estime que je produis pour tout
le monde et je produis pour pour chaque
chaque bourse je vois les raisins
muscales 2,50 juste avant de venir je
suis passé sur le marché de l' marin
4,90 le même raisin donc c'est du simple
au double he permettez que je prenne une
grappe signaler aussi il faut qu'on
défende nos producteurs ils n'ont pas
les mêmes règles du jeu que que les pays
voisins donc si on veut faire aimer
l'Europe là aussi peut-être viiller à
harmoniser ça il faut peut-être oui et
autre sujet c'est de plus en plus
difficile de s'assurer c'est très cher
ça veut dire que un producteur de fruits
c'est il joue un petit peu à la roulette
russe est-ce que vous vous accepteriez
qu'en une nuit vous perdiez la totalité
de votre salaire de l'année ah ben non
non c'est pour ça qu' ah oui vous vous
prenez le risque je suis obligé de
l'assumer sinon je fais autre chose
l'année dernière coup de froid dans la
nuit j'ai perdu la totalité de ma
production d'abricot et ça fait 5 ans et
ça vous pousse pas à changer de culture
oui si je fais de la fraise maintenant
parce que parce que c'est un peu plus
sûr il y a c'est un peu moins sensible à
ces aléas climatiques là il y a d'autres
problèmes mais qui sont plus facilement
maîtrisables Nicolas P que je vous
écoutais j'avais l'œil sur vos
aubergines elles sont d'une fermeté
c'est extraordinaire ramasser du jour on
peut aller voir là où vous les ramasser
allez je vous y
[Musique]
enmène qu'est-ce que c'est beau c'est
magnifique ces aubergines c'est brillant
vous n'êtes pas bio vous non moi je suis
pas bio j'ai une exploitation qui est
certifiée HVE haute valeur
environnementale c'est ça on fait pas
n'importe quoi et c'est pour ça que
j'aurais tendance à dire que de toute
manière peu ou prou je pense que bio'y
viendrait voilà mais la lutte biologique
c'est c'est pas quelque chose que
j'utilise pas le problème qu'on a eu
c'est que quand je me suis installé il y
a 20 ans on nait pas les connaissances
qu'on a maintenant moi à titre personnel
je n'accepte pas de perdre ma récolte
parce que sur l'hôtel de la sauvegarde
de la planète on peut dire vous venez
dire le contraire vous dites je passerai
au bio donc ça veut dire que même ce
petit oui je passerai au bio quand les
30 ans de recherche nécessaires à
réguler un bon nombre de problèmes qu'on
a le permettront donc donneront des
produits naturels mais qui auront la
même efficacité que le phytosanitaire
exacte voir mieux voir mieux mieux tout
simplement monsieur le sénateur est-ce
que c'est un discours que vous entendez
souvent en bcluse je crois qu'il faut
faire confiance aux producteurs ils ont
intégré tous comme nous tous élus locaux
chacun dans son domaine la sobéé le fait
qu'il faut faire autrement il faut faire
[Musique]
confiance Jean-Baptiste on n pas quitté
le vent tout de la journée qui est
toujours au-dessus de nous mais je suis
heureux de me retrouver ce soir au
milieu des vignes parce dans le voclus
c'est important les vignes on est où là
on est au domaine de la camarette chez
Nancy Gontier une vigneronne
exceptionnelle qui travaille le bio
alors on est au dos des dentelles de
montmail baom de Venise gigondass le
Château Neuf du pape il du lourd on est
vraiment dans une région de vin et tiens
je vois la vigonne là bienvenue chez
nous NANC enchanté bonjour Nancy
qu'est-ce que vous faisiez là au moment
où on arrivait on est en train de
vérifier la maturité des grains pour
prévoir la future vendance dans les
quelques jours à venir incessamment là
je peux goûteroui vous pouvez voilà
voulez goûter monsieur le sénateur
regardez merci pour justement décider de
la date de vendange on va plus goûter la
peau et le grain que le jus et la pulpe
en elle-même pe va rééler la maturité
exactement la pulpe elle est blanche oui
donc ce qui donne la couleur au vin
rouge c'est bien la macération des des
peaux exactement c'est le temps de
contact entre le jus qui est sur la dans
la pulpe et le contact avec la peau les
pépins tout se trouve en fait dans ces
deux choses et cette petite pellicule
blanche qu'on peut voir sur les raisins
qui va s'appeler la pruine c'est
vraiment aussi une matière très
importante pour nous parce que là vous
allez retrouver tous les sulfites
naturels les conservateurs naturels qui
nous permettent en en vinification d'en
mettre beaucoup moins et de faire des
vins meilleurs pour la santé et vous
avez choisi d'être bio ou ici oui c'est
un choix personnel alors je me suis
toujours dit cette terre elle manque un
peu de vie parce que du temps de mes
grands-parents c'était vraiment
l'explosion des produits chimiques donc
mes grands-parents comme beaucoup
d'agriculteurs se sont dit super on va
utiliser ça ça va nous économiser quand
même beaucoup de fatigue et beaucoup de
temps on les utilise bon quand même la
base de nos raisins que l'on va produire
chaque année c'est quand même la terre
dans laquelle la plante va vivre donc on
s'est dit quand ma sœur est arrivée en
2009 on va faire le passage en
conversion bio et on va voir si cette
terre nous le rend et si elle Ren oui la
terre elle renaî quand vous creusez vous
sentez qu'il y a de la vie voyez Vincent
la terre Renat et c'est leuse qui Rena
non si le grenache c'est le grand sépage
du Sud exactement plus précisément ici
d'autres spages vienent si mêl comme la
Sira qui est un améliorant mais aussi
sainceau mourvère Carignan également ce
sont les CIN sépages rouges ou rosé qui
nous sont autorisés et on va dire qu'un
assemblage de ces cinq sépages va
vraiment faire une identité parfaite du
l'identité vos cuisienes nonan si j'ai
goûté votre raisin j'ai bu vos paroles
mais maintenant il faut goûter le
[Musique]
vin domaine de la
grenachette
on est à 15 km à vol d'oiseau de Château
neu du pape qui est une appellation qui
va jusqu'à 13 cpages ça veut dire que
c'est dans l'essence même du vauluse que
d'être des vins d'assemblage on fait pas
de monoépages ici non cette obligation
de faire des assemblages va nous
permettre de conserver notre identité et
la complexité de nos produits
Jean-Baptiste cet assemblage de ces
pages différents chacun avec ses
caractères il est un peu à l'image de la
société voclusienne avec la mixité elle
est là notre identité entre alpie camarg
carodanien Drome provençal et un
croisement géographique assez incroyable
entre Italie Espagne nord- sudud c'est
ce que le vin nous raconte en tout cas
et c'est ce que le vin nous rappelle
alors évidemment c'est un combat tous
les jours parce qu'il faut que chacun
trouve sa place il faut qu'il y ait pas
de fracture ent t les territoires en
mettant en valeur ce qu'on sait faire et
et que NANC incarne on va trinquer à la
vie à la
VI et on va aller voir une chef qui met
la vie dans la terre et dans ses
produits
[Musique]
nous sommes à la feenière ici à
lourdmarin qui fut le restaurant célèbre
de re Samut et de gu Samut qui
maintenant a été transmis à leur fille
Nadia ah tiens
est ça
va un honneur en fait non c'est un
plaisir c'est chouette de nous recevoir
c'est ma petite cuisine potager en fait
j'aime bien cuisiner dedans et y
réfléchir
monsieur sénateur a revêtu la tenue de
sa nouvelle charge qui est d'être ton
comis de cuisine
exactement de ça je pense même je
l'amène à devenir nourriissier
nourricier c'est une élévation de
conscience sur l'alimentation un peu
plus profond quand même alors mais je
crois qu'il est déjà gagné à la cause
j'ai travaillé sur une loi qui s'appelle
le zan qui consiste à arrêter
d'artificialiser les sols et notamment
ça consiste à arrêter d'artificialiser
les terres nourrissières il agit pour
qu'on se nourrisse mieux j'aiess mon
niveau beaucoup donc on est m'spire
qu'est-ce que tu nous as préparé
aujourd'hui et bien en fait ici on est
dans le potager vraiment c'est la
continuité et j'aime bien amener les
gens à comprendre justement ce vivant au
travers d'ingrédients qu'on a trouvé et
là il me resta quelques fleurs de
courgette on a du cosmos oui on a de la
bourrache ouais donc on va prendre cette
petite courgette on va la farcir ensuite
normalement bah on la chauffe un petit
peu juste ce qu'il faut avant le service
je vais te laisser terminer le dîner
merci et pendant ce tempslà le temps est
venu de de revenir un peu sur notre
journée venez à côté de moi
Jean-Baptiste ou on s'est promené toute
la journée j'ai senti que quelques part
il y avait un peu une nostalgie d'un
d'un vlus perdu que tout le monde essaie
de retrouver comment ne pas être
nostalgique ce vclus qu'onon qu'on a
évoqué cette lumière de ce jardin de la
France qui qui était nous j'ai été
frappé par une chose dans les rues des
villages là où il y a des cafés des
restaurants des places publiques les
touristes ont remplacé c'est les proveno
alors nous ne sommes pas pour le
tourisme de masse le tourisme de masse
massacre la fontaine de beauaucluse
massacre à Roussillon le Colorado
Provençal les Dentelles de Montmirail
donc ce n'est pas du tout ça la solution
et on travaille à travers les les parcs
régionaux à travers les grands sites à
préserver à réguler à trouver le juste
le juste milieu quel est la
transformation que doit mener le vauluse
moi je ne crois qu' qu'and l'agire
locale en on agit bien que de près je
croit dans le pouvoir des des communes
et des élus municipaux simplement il
faut les aider moi j'invite vraiment
chacun à à s'engager le rideau va
bientôt tomber sur cette émission le
spectacle du vauluse se termine il me
reste à vous remercier comme Festival
d'Avignon un petit peu comme au Festival
d'Avignon mais c'est l'âme de
jeanvillard qui est au-dessus de nous
merci Nadia on va déguster dans une
seconde on se retrouve très bientôt sur
public
sénna et vous pouvez bien sûr retrouver
cette émission et tous les épisodes de
manger ses beautés sur la plateforme
publsenat.fr c'était manger svutter avec
Mutualia la mutuelle des
[Musique]
territoires